you know for 24 hours that an  unregistered was a set magical beasts  loose in New York yes where is this man  here to go with the case full of  monsters huh  huge travelers first it's a standard do  you know anything about the Wizarding  community in America we don't let things  loose hey mister English guy I think  your egg is hatching you wiped his  memory right there no matter what no  magic there not one wizard sorry we call  the muggles  I don't think I'm dreaming okay the way  ain't got the brains to make this up  disappearing without a trace witches  live among us we've lived in the shadows  for too long  a scholar who does this protect  yes  danger he says Dania  this is related to Grindelwald attacks  in Europe this could mean war we got a  plan right guys they need our help  what's that everything that came out of  the case  a lot another one guy  I refuse to bow down any long  I was running out let's just commander  you